hello I'm Charlie if you know me then
you probably know me as that weird
little teenager who likes to make videos
about cups of tea but today I'm here to
talk about something that isn't about
tea today my friends I am here to tell
you that I have a nerdfighter and what's
today's mission nerdfighters to decrease
worldsuck because today is the day of
the secret project for awesome oh well I
guess it's not secret anymore but so how
do you plan to decrease worldsuck
charlie isn't that obvious I'm here to
pick up my favorite charity the fact is
cancer isn't very nice one in three
people's lives is somehow affected by
cancer and yeah it's it's not very nice
it's that it's the problem heck my gran
died of cancer I know it's not very nice
but even though cancer is a big problem
there is a deeper problem inside the
world of the problem of cancer you see
cancer is generally associated with the
very old or the very young and the
people in between don't get as much
attention oh my god it's the most
awesome sent a screen shot ever but I
can't talk about it very much now
because we've got to go back to the
video which means when a teenager gets
the disease um they're not always
entirely sure what to do if you're
facing treatment and you're under 16
then you're likely to get placed in with
a load of little kids and if you're
facing treatment and you're over 16 then
you're likely to get placed in with a
load of old people neither of which is
very good for a teenager which is why I
want to tell you about teenage cancer
trust teenage cancer trust because
teenage cancer trust are here to help us
teens fight cancer it may be a lower
number of teenagers getting cancer but
teenagers still do get cancer and they
still do need to be looked after
so go teenage cancer trust I'll put a
load of links over there in the video
description go check them out go donate
don't do whatever you can and go and
help us to crease worldsuck good luck
with the project nerdfighters I'll see
you soon oh and everyone else do you
like watches my videos hello I haven't
been around for a while have I I'll
probably post a new video tomorrow ok
thanks bye